pour commencer on va vous parler un peu
de l'ukraine qui tente vous s'intéresse
à la situation actuelle en ukraine
allez-y lever la main tous génial qui
parmi vous et au fait de la situation en
ukraine qui peut me dire exactement
quelle est la situation dans l'est
quelles sont les positions de l'armée
russe
quels sont les opinions des habitantes
donetsk des habitants de marioupol qui
sait dans quelles conditions se sont
tenues le référendum du week-end dernier
et même si c'est qu'il y avait un
référendum le week-end dernier
aujourd'hui la presse est passé à autre
chose les médias en chalet sujet et
c'est normal néanmoins il ya maintenant
une enfance dans une absence
d'information
est ce que vous êtes confortable avec
cette absence d'information on va
continuer un peu avec la hongrie qui a
entendu parmi vous parler de la taxe
internet
allez-y lever la main génial mais je
vous expliquais que bien que sacré
occupent les hongrois c'est le cadet de
leurs soucis parce que aujourd'hui qui
s'est permis vous que six officiels
hongrois ont été banni à vie du
territoire américain
parce qu'ils ont tenté d'effectuer un
chantage aux entreprises américaines
telles que coca cola qui sait qu'elles
mêmes états unis pensent à retirer la
hongrie de la liste officielle de leurs
alliés et enfin qui sait que la hongrie
risquent d'être exclues de ce qu'on
appelle la community de démocratie et
donc d'être reconnu par la communauté
internationale comme une nation
antidémocratique
l'information est très peu apparu en
france et donc c'est normal qu'ils vous
ne sachiez pas il n'a aucune raison
culpabiliser nous l'avons trouvé que
deux sites en langue française qui en
parlait lalibre.be et la voix de la
russie points et rue
autant dire que ce maillot avec ses deux
petits exemples on arrive à la
conclusion que l'information était
imparfaite
elle a encore fait et cela pour
plusieurs raisons
elle peut être manquantes comme on l'a
vu pour l'ukraine les médias ne peuvent
pas couvrir tous les sujets de
l'actualité
elle est aussi manquantes parfois par
volonté parce que certains sujets ne
veulent pas être traités
est ce que vous vous souvenez de ce qui
s'est passé en 2004 en côte d'ivoire
alors pour les plus jeunes d'entre nous
en 2004 l'armée française ouvre le feu
sur une manifestation d'ivoiriens
désarmer les médias français ont mis une
semaine avant d'en parler et pourquoi
pas ce que les médias étrangers en avons
parlé et sous la pression il on est
obligé d'en parler
l'information elle est aussi imparfaite
parce qu'elle peut être mauvaise par
omission ou non avec arnaud nous pensons
que la solution à cette imperfection de
l'information peut venir de l'homme
partage est plutôt que posséder c'est
l'économie de partage
c'est tout simplement la nouvelle
mondialisation le 21ème siècle alors
comme l'a dit le très sérieux new york
times
le partage est à la propriété ce que
l'ipod est aux lecteurs 8 beast est ce
que le panneau solaire est à la mine de
charbon c'est propre
neuf et postmoderne alors les communes
de partage se base sur trois piliers
dans un premier temps dépenser moins
alors c'est une préoccupation pour nous
tous aujourd'hui en raison de
l'augmentation du coût de la vie
c'est aussi faire plus c'est tout simple
si vous donnez un homme un portefeuille
de 100 euros si chaque activité et coûte
20 euros il pour en faire cinq si vous
réduit si vous parvenez pardon à réduire
le coût de chaque activité à 10 euros
ils pourront faire disent dépenser moins
faire plus mais c'est surtout faire plus
ensemble les hommes ensemble ont la
capacité de faire plus que l'homme seul
c'est le principe de synergie l'ensemble
supérieur à l'ensemble à l'ensemble
supérieure à la quantité
nous pensons que l'économie de partage
sur le futur
si vous regardez 20 ans en arrière quand
un homme voulait se loger il se disait
il y un hôtel pour ça et la véraison
désormais nous pouvons tous ceux
impliqués avec des sites comme airbnb
nous pouvons tous proposer un logement à
un passager qui est dans notre ville et
qui désirent se loger et donc airbnb
c'est dépenser moins offrir plus
et surtout offrir ensemble est ce que
vous saviez que en seulement quatre ans
donc en 2012 airbnb a vendu plus de
nuitées que l'ensemble du groupe hilton
donc c'est un exemple parfait qui montre
que grâce à l'homme on a amélioré le
logement pour continuer quand un homme
voulait aller d'un point a à un point b
il prenait un train il ya vingt ans la
paresse est totalement normal et
aujourd'hui nous pouvons aussi tous tous
impliqués avec des sites comme la blague
à nous pouvons tous avoir accès au
covoiturage
savez-vous même d'ailleurs que dans
l'ensemble des états unis il ya
maintenant des lignes entières
d'autoroutes sont réservées aux voitures
qui utilisent le covoiturage le
covoitureur encore une fois c'est
dépenser moins offrir plus de
destinations clés réseau ferré et
surtout voyagé ensemble
c'est un autre exemple de l'humain qui a
amélioré un service nous pensons à
nouveau que l'homme sera la solution aux
carences de l'information et c'est donc
pour cela que nous avons créé boost have
pour créer gustave nous sommes partis
d'un principe un principe assez simple
un principe qui dit que la visibilité et
la publication de vos idées de vos
travaux de vos pensées du jour ne
doivent dépendre uniquement que de votre
capacité à vous exprimer
elles ne doivent pas dépendre du nombre
d'amis que vous avez sur les réseaux
sociaux
elle ne doit pas dépendre non plus de la
ligne éditoriale d'un journal elle ne
doit pas non plus dépendre de vos
capacités à référencer un blog sur les
moteurs de recherche
elle ne doit pas non plus être limité en
140 caractères pour cela nous avons
voulu créer un site sur lequel chacun
pourrait avec des compétences simple
donner ses idées donner un témoignage
parlé de quelqu'un sujets qui
l'intéressent
comme tous les projets ont une histoire
une histoire qui a éclairé une petite
somme petite lumière dans la tête de
leurs créateurs
nous avons la nôtre aussi cette histoire
c'est celle d'une discussion
une discussion que nous n'avons pas
exécuté une discussion à laquelle nous
avons assisté ces discussions rassemblé
trois étudiants étrangers
une habitante de tel-aviv une habitante
d'un kibboutz
il ya un immigré
les seniors autant vous dire qu'au début
on avait un petit peu peur de la voir de
la tournure qu'allait prendre cette
conversation et à la fin des fins à la
fin de cette conversation en laissant
les spectateurs et des acteurs êtres
conversations sont tous dit quelque
chose
eh ben on appelait on a appris
aujourd'hui et ils ont appris parce que
cette conversation n'était pas basé sur
une comparaison ce chiffre plus ou moins
vrai elle n'était pas basé sur une
opposition d'idéologie un petit peu un
petit peu aux combes être même
complètement opposés au lieu de ça
chacun s'était juste contenté d'un
témoignage qui expliquait ben voilà
comment eux personnellement dans leur
quotidien il arrivait à expiration afin
de pouvoir continuer ce qui les touche
et danse dans ce dans ce conflit et
surtout commencent à impacter leur vie
de tous les jours et on s'est rendu
compte qu'avec ces trois témoignages on
a réussi tous ensemble apprendre
beaucoup plus de choses que ce qu'on
avait appris dans les médias que ce
qu'on avait appris par les par les
moyens traditionnels d'information et
donc avec alexandre on a commencé à
réfléchir un petit peu et à se dire bien
imaginer un système dans lequel si on a
envie de se renseigner sur un sujet on
aurait juste par un simple clic accès à
non pas trois témoignages mais une
dizaine une centaine un millier pour
justement grâce à tout ça un peu à la
manière d'akron funding récupérer un
maximum d'informations et c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui on a voulu lancer ce site
bien entendu quand on parle de liberté
d'expression et notamment quand on parle
de liberté d'expression sur internet
on a toujours des petits a priori on est
en tête des dérapages
on pourrait discuter des heures sur les
limites de la liberté d'expression
aujourd'hui on va juste vous résumer
certaines phrases avec alex estimons que
la liberté d'expression a quand même une
limite la limite du respect de l'autre
et ce ne sont que nous voulons toujours
gardé sur notre projet
aujourd'hui avec vous on fait un pari on
fait un saut en fait même un peu on
souhaite que demain vous soyez tous
acteurs de l'information que tous vous
ayez les moyens de diffuser vos
connaissances et vos informations
alors forcément je serai peut-être amené
à penser que votre opinion n'intéresse
que votre petite personne et que
l'information dont vous disposez ne
mérite ou font pas d'être partagée eh
bien c'est faux c'est faux pour
plusieurs raisons dans un premier temps
il existera toujours quelqu'un sur cette
terre qui sera fasciné par ce que vous
avez à dire quelqu'un pour qui le texte
que vous aurez écrit aura une vraie
résonance cette personne vous ne
connaissez peut-être pas mais elle
existe et ça nous pouvons vous le
promettre
comme disait aristote nous sommes au
fond que des sommes qu'ils animent au
pardon doués de raison et de discours
chaque personne capable de raisonner à
un devoir de s'exprimer la seconde
raison à nous vient de francis bacon qui
décidément on faisait beaucoup de choses
francis bacon a dit la lecture amène à
l'homme la plénitude
le discours l'assurance mais seule
l'écriture apporte l'exactitude
écrire c'est poser des mots sur ce que
vous pensez poser des mots c'est
vraiment définir le fond de votre pensée
et en ça vous pensez mieux dans un
dernier temps écrire c'est aussi être
capable de lire est lien c'est un
discours en un partage être deux et à la
manière un peu d'un sophocle qui
utilisaient la maïeutique afin
d'accoucher des idées vous pourrez être
inspiré par d'autres idées et donc
remettre en question ce que vous pensiez
à qui et ça ça n'a pas de prix
alors bien sûr tout comme les hôtels
continue de vendre des nuitées et tout
comme les trains continuent de desservir
la france vous continuerez à vous
informer auprès des médias mais
aujourd'hui nous pensons qu'une vraie
alternative est possible nous pensons
que l'information peut passer de l'homme
à l'homme
actuellement la formation passe de
l'homme aux médias à l'homme et qu'on le
veuille ou non il ya forcément une part
d'interprétation dans ce schéma
triangulaire de l'homme à l'homme nous
avons une discussion qui est plus direct
plus vrai et ainsi une amélioration des
lacunes de l'information
son goût star nous avons deux objectifs
c'est de permettre à chacun d'exprimer
ses connaissances et de faire ressortir
son information
c'est pour ça qu'on a pris deux exemples
très simple pour montrer toutes les
capacités cette plate forme au début
lorsqu'on a présenté gusta va notre
entourage
notre famille nos amis nos contacts
professionnels beaucoup de choses
surmonter beaucoup d'idées beaucoup
d'opportunités
aujourd'hui on vous en présente deux de
première la première concerne le monde
scientifique sans limite de secteurs
sans limite de domaine aujourd'hui 70%
des travaux des scientifiques ne seront
jamais publié vous n'aurez donc jamais
accès à 70% du travail de l'élite
mondiale pourtant ces travaux s'ils ne
sont pas publiées c'est pas parce qu'ils
sont mauvais ça peut être parce qu'ils
ne correspondent pas au sujet du mois
d'un magazine ça peut être aussi parce
qu'il est perdu c'est de l'information
est perdue sur un bloc n'est pas
référencé sur les moteurs de recherche
et ça peut tout simplement être un
document qui est perdu dans une boîte
mail et que personne ne lira et ses
documents et finiront sur l'ordinateur
du scientifique dans un dossier articles
non publié pourtant ces articles il
pourrait intéresser il pourrait
intéresser déjà un scientifique à
l'autre bout du globe qui travaille sur
la même chose mais pour aussi intéressé
vous lors de vos un dossier rendre à
l'école un élément vous avez envie de
envie d'apprendre une simple curiosité
que vous avez envie d'éclaircir et c'est
pour ça qu'on se font offrir cette
possibilité aux scientifiques de bus de
poster régulièrement ce qu'ils savent
tous leurs travaux avec comme seule
limite leur liberté
des mecs qui tend niveau je me dire qui
est cet homme cet homme c'est millan mai
lan c'est un ami à nos îles et hongrois
mylan grâce à un seul papier ce gusta
ville a réussi à nous parler des
préoccupations quotidiennes des endroits
tout ce dont nous vous avons parlé au
début de ce talk c'est mylène qui nous
l'a appris sans que cette information
soit disponible en france imaginez
demain avoir accès d'un clic à des
dizaines des centaines de mille ans des
hommes des femmes capables de penser de
réfléchir et surtout de retranscrire
leurs connaissances et leurs
informations
c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui avec vous
dans notre école avec nos professeurs
avec nos amis avec vous tous on a
souhaité donner vie à ce projet afin
d'améliorer la qualité et la diffusion
de l'information et de la connaissance
et honnêtement la plus belle surprise ce
serait de nous réveiller demain matin et
de voir que tous pendant la nuit
vous avez décidé de partager devenir
acteurs de l'information de la
connaissance et surtout que vous ayez
pris un grand plaisir
je remercie pour votre attention